[Applaudissements]
les pouvoirs basés à laisser tout seul a
laissé tout seul
la mare hier l'état a joué sept
personnes ça va te reverrai tard tu es
content ils sont vachement sympa en fait
elle a battu ses peines qui chante à
côte aux fées contente de voir tu es
content de me voir jouer
il est pas content de me voir tubize où
mes 3 way et padraig autant me va je
vous souhaite et on scanne j'aurai moi
je sais pas montré calme
je souhaite un bon prime alors j'espère
que ça va bien se passer bien ça va bref
au sud ouest
ça va nous faire
c'est rien c'est rien c'est agir et en
plus il joue dur que c'est lui et vous
les frais mais non mais je suis arrivé
un peu vite n'y a pas de soucis vous
saignez c'est grave quand même j'ai pas
vu venir et la pagaille est ce que des
métiers qui s'occupera donc c'est bien
gros bisous
je voulais juste dire un truc en plus
gilles c'est un amour il voulait faire
et je voulais faire après voulait faire
un peu de pub pour la nouvelle star
parce que